a13 time on star 10 time Gold Glove
winner and joining us on behalf of Sony
Playstation and the cover athlete MLB
the show 17 jr. how are you good how
about you
no complaints what are you more proud of
that the 10 time Gold Gloves or 13 time
all-star Gold Glove where do you keep
them all oh what's really interesting is
that I had a I moved into a house and I
only opened one until I moved into my
current house but I opened them all up
because I didn't have any place to put
it out you know at that time you don't
think about having a trophy room so you
just put it on the mantel and let it go
but when I moved into the current house
I actually built a little trophy room
it's not a little trophy when there's so
many trophies that yeah so you built an
addition for your trophies not just a
big ole office I like that how long does
it take for I go into the house before I
know what you did for a living a lot
yeah I don't have any pictures of me in
uniform other than in my office
everything I could take that back I've
got one leaving into the hallway to the
bedroom and that's it really that's just
a picture of all of us that burn a well
senior painting that Verna well senior
did for me everything else is in my
office and unless you go downstairs but
no I try to you know keep my house as
normal as possible you know it's it's a
home it's not a museum I mean I want
people to live in there well it's the
coolest piece of memorabilia you have I
think the coolest thing that I have is
the stuff that the kids done for in
school for me also nothing
sports-related know just the little
little kid stuff the pottery with the
handprint
like that III can't your son looks
exactly like you and of course a
football - yeah how good were you at
football because I know your son played
football at Arizona oh I had more
football first than baseball and were
you wide receiver at Moeller
yes I was I'm good were you um like I
said I had more offers the football than
baseball Ohio State
no Oklahoma oh yeah but they didn't
throw the football back then today it
was a position switch for me oh come on
if Ohio State it off to your foot
football scholarship actually my brother
went to Ohio State he was there with uh
Vinnie Clark and Carlos snow and Jeff
Graham and let's see I think Chris
Carter just graduated but Chris was
there a lot so you know I got a chance
to go up there and watch the battle
between Ohio State Michigan
wait so you but you didn't answer the
question would you have played football
for Ohio State reach down to jr. my
brother went there that's a yes thank
you no I just said my brother went there
I know but that's that's a that's a
non-denial
yeah you I don't know dad let you go cuz
you were gonna be the number one pick in
the draft but would your down yeah he
didn't care you know the one thing about
my dad is that he lets you take your
your own career path you know the one
thing that I I stressed in my house is
you know hey this is not my career that
you're gonna you know that you're going
through it's what you want to do and I
never let you know I tell my kids don't
be a what if so go out there and play
all these sports and the one that you
like you know that's the the one that
I'll support you and I'll support you
and everything
my little guy takes it to the extreme
you know trey is try and tear
you know one two sports my little guy
thinks that four and five sports are
okay at one time
he's a Ken Griffey junior joining us
behalf of Sony Playstation the cover
athlete of MLB the show seventeen how
big we're video game when did video
games become big in your world I started
out with Atari and pong so and then it
just you know then it was Dreamcast and
Nintendo and Sony and Microsoft and then
back to Sony so it's definitely been a
big part of our lives I mean at any
given time you'll have three generations
of griffeys playing each other but the
only problem is that the older Griffey
and the two younger griffeys they seem
to team up on the middle griffey which
is me do you have the hat on backwards
when you're playing yeah have you ever
looked though at how how you were ranked
in those did you ever problem cuz these
guys now have a problem with how they're
ranked madden you know if you're ranked
lower these guys get upset did you ever
have a problem with how you were
portrayed in a video game well they
didn't have rankings back then so
everybody was pretty much the same other
than Bo Jackson and Tecmo Bowl but with
all world on that you got him you was
yeah you were undefeated but now the
rankings weren't as popular as they are
now what do you remember about Bo I
still talked about Bo is unbelievable on
and off the field you know just a career
that was cut short of an injury but
still one of the the greatest athletes
who ever put on a football uniform and a
baseball uniform what the would the
baseball career been like have you just
concentrated on that scary he had a ball
to me and I took like three steps and oh
and I sure thought I'm had him at second
and he was rounding second and I had to
double pump and I actually threw the
ball to the pitcher who was standing on
the mound because I was afraid that he
was gonna try to score
you think he would have been a
hall-of-famer yeah and he had that arm
too I mean he had it covered so much
ground he was so fast
down down the first base line you know
and being a high handed batter yeah I
tell everybody he was the biggest guy
I've ever seen
I'm the biggest guy over 200 pounds and
the fastest guy I've seen over 200
pounds and the other one is Diaw only
200 pounds who do you think was faster I
think whoever got the the best jump was
gonna win cuz Dionne acknowledges Bo's
greatness but Dionne says now we saw him
at the Super Bowl Dionne said he's the
fastest over-40 person in the world what
do you think that is over 40 person in
the world yeah okay I wouldn't I went
and I wouldn't bet against him but I
would like to see him and Darrell green
race whoo yeah you know what and and I
think he acknowledges Darrell Green you
know is a guy who could probably still
run a sub for 340 there if you want to
give us a plug again about the Sony
Playstation before we say goodbye far
away well yeah it's a lot of fun I got a
chance to do the motion capture and the
voiceover you can go into career mode
which is pretty awesome that you can
choose your own path we talked about
everybody talks about passing and which
way they go so you can honestly you know
if the team wants to move you to a
different position you say no your
career path takes a direction and if you
say yes it could take a different
direction and you could be in the big
leagues you couldn't so it's a lot of
interesting things that go along with
this game kind of like you your career
path could have been football player at
Ohio State but you turned down an offer
to go play baseball no I'd have probably
gone to Michigan really was it yeah only
because you know one of my friends Vader
Murray who passed away went to Michigan
and as a freshman and sophomore he was
my big brother I'm older well there
got a lot of guys from Cincinnati who
went to Michigan to play football but
now that that might have been tough
being from Cincinnati going playing up
there at Michigan but I've been fun when
you came back to Columbus to play yeah
hey good luck with the game and great to
visit with you Thank You jr. thank you
you take it easy all right
that's ken griffey jr. a Sony
Playstation and he's cover athlete MLB
the show 17 not bad numbers there for
jr. 630 homers 2700 hits and played 22
years in league the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience